Це не типові фотографії з випускного. Ніхто не радіє і не святкує.
Але випускники школи села Богданівка під Києвом хотіли відзначити
цю важливу життєву подію саме так.
Я хотів би, щоб світ побачив, що сталося з моєю школою,
щоб побачили, що я, як учень цієї школи, я не зациклююся на тому,
що вона згоріла, я все ще живу, насолоджуюся життям,
що я закінчив 11 клас, не впав у депресію.
Школу відремонтували перед повномасштабним вторгненням,
розповідає директорка. Тут навчалися 400 учнів.
Під час окупації росіяни перетворили школу на свою базу.
Вони стягували туди меблі з будинків у селі, побутову техніку,
зокрема, пральні машини.
Цього всього на коридорах у нас не було. Це все вони настягували.
Коли російських військових витіснили з-під Києва, вони підпалили школу.
У цій залі була їдальня й актова зала, тут сміялися діти,
а зараз - просто погляньте на неї. Російські військові
не пошкодували нічого. Коли вони відступали, то підпалили навіть автобуси,
які стояли надворі. Це показова відповідь на заяви Росії про те,
що вона не зачіпає цивільну інфраструктуру.
Директорка школи показує, що залишилося від її кабінету.
Тут був мій стіл, по обидва боки - шафи з документами.
І тут - велика стіна з журналами, з книгами видачі свідоцтв, атестатів,
з усіма важливими документами, які зберігає кожна школа.
Звісно, коли вперше зайшли до школи, це був просто жах.
Коли ти ходиш кожного дня сюди на роботу, вкладаєш свою душу,
свій час, інколи жертвуєш своєю відпусткою, як я, так і вчителі наші.
Учні закінчували навчальний рік у сусідньому селі, частково - дистанційно.
Усі шкільні спогади лишилися тут, у рідній школі.
Тут усі парти стояли ось так, всі мали сидіти в ряди, але ми сиділи отак
- за однією партою, усі разом, по 16 людей.
Ось тут у нас стояв кулер і чайник.
Ми дуже добре зараз спілкуємося і тоді спілкувалися
з минулим 11 класом, ми приходили до них, тут у них була своя атмосфера,
ми чайок пили разом, їли.
Це було класно, потім ще фотографувалися. Це було класно.
Коли дивишся на школу, згадуєш ті часи, коли всім було весело,
грали в ігри, вчилися, коли приколи, коли ділилися з однокласниками всім.
А так - сумно дивитися на неї.
Ти провчився тут 10 років - ці всі моменти, спогади, відео, постійні приколи якісь.
І це дійсно було настільки складно. Ти дивишся, і ніби тебе зруйнували зсередини.
З початку повномасштабного вторгнення понад 3300 навчальних закладів
зазнали пошкоджень або були зруйновані.
Анна Новосад - колишня міністерка освіти, а нині - активістка у сфері освіти.
Благодійний фонд savED, яким вона керує, допомагає школам
відновити офлайн-навчання й відбудувати приміщення.
Вона каже: поки кінця війні не видно, потрібно міркувати
над швидкими рішеннями для школярів.
Масштаби руйнувань - величезні. Щоб відбудувати таку школу, як ця,
потрібно від семи до восьми мільйонів євро і кілька років часу.
У таких громадах, як Богданівка, де освітня інфраструктура
знищена повністю російськими військовими, потрібні тимчасові рішення
- такі як школи модульної конструкції. Або треба переобладнати
інші місцеві споруди, такі як будинки культури або приватні будинки.
Усе, що вціліло, за можливості треба перетворювати на школи,
щоб діти, які повернулися, мали доступ до освіти.
Ці школярі - такі ж, як і діти в будь-якій іншій країні.
Вони мріють про великі досягнення, хорошу роботу,
подорожі по всьому світу й насичене доросле життя.
Хочеться миру в країні, бо воюють всі рідні, це важко.
Миру, перемоги України, вступити (у виш - ред.)
і далі просуватися по життю, не стояти на місці.
Один з хлопців хоче бути айтівцем, інший - психологом,
інші поки не визначилися. Утім війна вже змінила їхнє життя й назавжди лишила відбиток.
Я дійсно подорослішав. Я став більш відповідальним,
сміливішим, я почав розуміти, що я хочу, як цього досягти,
які плани будувати, як їх реалізувати.
Я почав більше цінувати життя. Прийшло усвідомлення того,
що в будь-який момент це все може зникнути, ракета прилетить - і все.
Тепер ми не такі вже й діти, тому що війна вплинула
на наш ментальний, моральний розвиток. Тому я просто хочу дожити до завтра,
це головна ціль. І кінець війни.
Поки боротьба на фронті триває,
школярі теж налаштовані боротися - за своє майбутнє.